tonight is a magical night where I
choose the cat it deserves a new life
going to the ball could get dangerous I
actually saw you perform memory back in
in the spring in Vegas you were there I
was there and I'm not a crier but I
cried and then I cried again watching
you sing and rescue I'm just wondering
just that song like your first entry
into that song when you first heard it
and it seemed like you have a real
emotional connection without it it's
something in the music of this song that
just taps into my emotions even just
hearing the music of it it just takes me
there I feel like I understand
Grizabella yeah I made me want to tell a
story and cry her tears yes and for you
I know you're not a singer which is hard
to believe watching this movie because
you're just stunning to listen to and I
know that Taylor gave you a private
concert when you heard beautiful goes
for the first time that was curious when
she sings a private concert for you
does she look in your eyes like break it
down for me she doesn't see her that's
literally what happened she was seeing
me the songs was the first time I'd
heard it with her lyrics and yeah she
was literally singing it to me so it was
just completely surreal and now just
very sweetly asked me at the end of it
if if that was okay she's really the
sweetest soul she and so one of the
themes in this movie is like being
selected as the Jellicle cat and that
means you're special and you've been
accepted do you each have a point in
your careers where you felt like the
Jellicle cat like the chosen like where
you finally felt like wow I'm being
recognized I think that moment comes
will you get that role that you've heard
about in Annie or that opportunity like
wow I got chosen what was your first cuz
you've had someone who writable moment I
guess I'll have to say drinker that was
my first um and I feel like I've had so
many moments like that ever since and I
that's why I can't have some 9lives huh
there you go you go yeah how about for
you yeah well the first ballet I ever
watched was the Nutcracker and I suppose
it was when I was on stage at the Royal
Ballet and I was doing the Nutcracker
bike on stage by myself for the first
time I'm just very emotional thinking
yeah that's kind of like full circle
yeah
what was the first musical you both saw
do you remember like live music or just
in general like the one that you connect
to that you made you sort of go wow
maybe this is what I want to do it's
funny but I don't think I have an answer
so that I think about it I'm the West
Side Story yeah I was quite small I
think I love that and how did it affect
you in the sense of did it make did it
inspire you to want to be a performer
definitely yeah yeah I mean also just
the same with cats the reason I love
this means clothes well I just think
with West Side Story that the Dancing's
so important as long as as well as the
singing so I think that definitely that
resonated with me yeah I saw I'll ask
you a different question I saw an
interview where you talked about
Grizabella and you said that you almost
filled her enter her room before you see
her yes and I was wondering if when you
perform as a singer as an actress in any
way do you do that at all is there a
preparation or a moment where you almost
like we can feel you before we see you
definitely especially if more so if it's
a character or within a storyline
if I'm performing just singing I do
depending on the song like to bring
whatever presents the song brings cuz I
like to it's to me storytelling more so
than a song enemy yeah
so I approach it with a character and as
a story yeah mm-hmm I'm gonna put yours
on the spot can I hear me out
yeah that was good I want a pearl now
[Laughter]
you never did no no I have a cat at home
and he never meows either they really do
know if they learn how to do it to get
your attention apparently I'm in their
home yeah do you have one but I know you
both went to Castle for this what do you
think what is one thing that you learned
in cat school that you think is actually
useful in life if anything I'd be
purring all the time I'd be clawing at
people I really haven't be using that in
my life to be more independent because
cats are independent I think yeah yes
and very curious and cautious yeah yeah
but I don't know that I learnt that in
cat school and then I like how they use
their senses like we made it tend to use
one by far more than the other you know
they use a sense of smell and then their
ears and then their eyes wander so we've
probably use our eyes then what it makes
you want to know more about how we use
our other senses that makes any sense
like maybe I should try to listen as how
does that look I think that just so
aware all the time you know we're yeah
in the moment but also very alert ready
for anything
mm-hmm watching this movie there's so
many incredible set pieces and just
moments and I think some of my favorite
moments are when you're all together mmm
so can you give me a sense of that
feeling on set because you're all from a
lot of you from different places
different generations different
performing styles known for different
films or different projects sort of that
sense of being together that excites me
already just hearing that that feel like
it inspired us on so much yeah
to just see cuz everybody was so great
at what they do you know and having such
respect for like a Judi Dench and Ian
McKellen and seeing everybody Berg and
Jason Derulo I mean just everybody you
know just
yeah so yeah yeah you move your
movements are just another level of
stunning just so gorgeous
I know Judy we're supposed to play your
role when she was younger see did you
talk to her you know what I didn't
that's what I should've did when I was
sitting in my my set cheered next I like
I'm with that this is Judy digit I
should have took the opportunity yes
very right
yeah yeah and what is your if you have a
personal catnip
something that sort of like excites you
whether it's a food for me it's gonna
sound really random but it's
spray-tanning and figure eyelashes and
obviously I'm ready to go that's funny
- shopping ok online or what do we yeah
anywhere anywhere yeah I think I do a
lot of online shopping on sets yeah and
if you were to describe yourselves using
attributes that we usually drop you use
to describe cats can can you do that I
think I can be I've been told I'm
mysterious before cats are quite
mysterious right
fierce yeah yeah yes I would definitely
say that and what at last question were
the first time you guys saw yourselves
in these as cats what was your reaction
well I was very I was curious to see
because we didn't get to see that while
we were filming so for us it was a new
discovery like wow that's what we were
working towards wow that's me as a cat
you know me wow that's what we created
yeah yeah yeah it was pretty something
to watch
how was your reaction when you first saw
yourself I didn't know if they'd shown
you guys anything ahead of time like if
you had an idea already wait until we
all saw it you sort of reacted at the
same yeah I saw at the same time as the
rest of the world really and yeah it
just took me a few seconds to get used
to not having my ears
yeah be completely different plays yeah
it's very very cool
what
[Music]
[Music]
concatenations on the film um when I was
a kid I saw cats for the first time what
did you think I loved it
and magical mr. Mistoffelees was the
song I caught in my head for like three
weeks I wonder if you will sing like a
tiny little bit with me
go Freddie a cat so clever as magic
either way uh something clearly I'm not
a singer but I know you both went to cat
school for this film I'm learning if
there's anything you can just sort of
show me teach me that you learned in cat
school like any sort of movement like
what do they teach you so one of the
first things we had to do was cats bump
noses when they meet okay you know when
that they sort of like each other out we
did a lot of that you know they have
which I think we improvised didn't
rivers made up some words yeah really
was their way into the mill oh but I
haven't done too much of the cat school
but Laurie was very adept at being
account for easier actors but just
because we're not cats
no they're human beings yes you are not
even pretending to be can trail but
looking for the cat within I wanted to
ask you you've had such an incredible
career and one of the themes of this
film is being chosen at random costumes
you have an incredible career and one of
the themes of this film is that being
chosen as the Jellicle cat yes you are
the chosen one you've been acknowledged
yes do you have a moment
a Jellicle moment where you were like
I've been selected this is this is an
incredible moment when I started yeah
you couldn't act in this country or in
America unless you're a member of the
Union and before you could become a
member of the Union you had to do 44
weeks of paid work but not in London not
on television and
in a film which meant she went and
worked outside of London and regional
theatres and after the 44th week my
Equity card arrived there única and I
knew I was an actor
for two oh one five
it's a pity these days because their
union has been rather destroyed by
politicians here and you don't have to
be a member anymore but if you are a
member of the Union and you feel
accepted and you're allowed to join in
the big man I know you both I love the
set moments where you were all together
you have Jennifer Hudson you have Taylor
Swift singing together that moment how
did it feel what does it like to sing
with Taylor Swift and Jennifer Hudson
well there are a couple I don't want to
spoil it okay yeah but there are a
couple because I think it's better to go
into this film without having seen mmm
or know anything about it and be
pleasantly surprised but there's a
moment where she enters there's moments
that you were sort of all come together
the choreography is so incredible I
imagine just the camaraderie and sort of
how that feels to be an ensemble cuz I
think ensemble cast must feel different
than maybe a one on one scene absolutely
I we spent three months together so the
relationships are very much real you
can't is it's difficult to fake that
stuff and just that shared enjoyment and
in those numbers when you're you know
doing take after take and something very
physical as well there's it's really
enjoyment in sharing that with a company
and I think this isn't an ensemble led
piece and it's hard and you know the
likes of Taylor Swift and Jennifer
Hudson were very much part of that there
was no you know there was no one who
kind of skipped out on on this stuff it
was very much
[Music]
great to see you can I get that reaction
again about how this is the last
interview of the day that was really
loud sorry for the astounding person is
such a fun movie I want to be catified
now that I've seen you guys so how do
you what if you could show me your
reaction when you first saw yourself
catified and then I took a picture of it
which she was illegal I thought yeah cuz
you weren't supposed to his all top
secret but on my own time yeah oh yeah
yeah oh my friend's family did to my mom
and then for Christmas she made playing
cards out of them she put my face so we
guess your mama's proud problem yes yes
did you guys because I was also like
there's certain songs from this even
from when I was a kid that I sing in the
shower did you guys sing in the shower
at home anybody else's songs yeah I mean
memory everyone eyes that song yeah
that's a great one you know what I've
just seen Jennifer Hudson uprated that
song yeah yeah in the most positive way
yeah yeah it's just Lauder it just sing
from their guts and the heart I can't
sing it their shirts were like shaking
from the vibrations really wild she was
she was just incredible it was
incredible to witness that
what other songs I think the Jellicle
[Music]
yeah I just learned I seen your random
beats what other random Taylor Swift's
new song yeah really got my head
beautiful guys
I kept singing about it's a name yeah
cuz I never heard her sing it cuz she
was singing you guys could describe
yourself in three words but using
expressions that we usually are words we
usually use for cats can you do that oh
whoa
too much thinking should I ask a
different question prowess oh that's
really good yeah
feline yeah love it and I know this
sounds really cheesy but in the song we
go a feline fearless faithful and true
and I feel like fearless faithful and
true are are like the words to describe
my character yeah yeah
protector of the tribe yes you were you
get to be comedy cat so what does comedy
can't get to do that the other cat's
doctor to do it was good I didn't have
to take cat school seriously the source
material for this is TS Eliot's famous
poems but they're not necessarily that
funny especially to a modern audience so
I guess myself and James Corden we were
in particularly tasked with liven up a
bit yeah challenge on yeah Dean the same
kind lady pops I did a number of things
just to try to jazz it up guys
I'm here for you I'm here to entertain
you and you do it and I'm here to go for
it and one last question was did you
bring any of that home with you did you
find yourself did it lead your life like
did you you know Mike was you've done so
much like do you did you walk into a
store and go to pay and go I wish no I
don't know I'm not a man that sings all
the time though so I was probably caught
in the hotel singing the songs for sure
yeah because I just sing all the time
and they're jeans the Android web of
music it does get in your head and you
Jesus sing that a lot but I didn't bring
the physicality I think we all
definitely tried to leave that at the
door whoever did kind of creep in one
time with my friends at the bar and they
called
a lot and I was like look I'm sorry it's
just my muscles kind of understand that
[Laughter]
meeting your friends I would think we
were mental if we did that outside of
the set yeah yeah but that's the beauty
of it yeah I'm not an actress cuz I
would have done that I would have been
doing that all along but can we go out
with a meow thank you very much
I got a cat bite so I've got plenty of
soul
spotlight and a drumroll please you say
yes
are you jealous you didn't see it Yeah
right so good-looking and you too with
all of this silly more these teach me
something because obviously clearly I
said we can't have a private class
little own but what you really want to
know that you don't know about the movie
what about the behind the scenes stuff
like that who is the biggest fan of
everybody in the cast in the cast
well since baby I am a cannon was one of
the best actor to me yes and and Robin
Williams
that was the to my two favorite actors
and I was here so good about them how
professional and how fast they catch
things and I was so surprised and I was
probably eight it hurts my not my
feeling in a bad way but I think I hurt
also by way cuz I never seen someone not
even don't give up but I am a Canon came
on stage and on one shot with the whole
show and even if some time he had to he
have these last moments his energy Katz
acting sing everything in West Point's
all beautiful I'm like he did forget the
text and he killed it all working so
hard to actually like looking great
doing the cat's right singing right
dancing right and acting right when you
have a man like him
and come over with duty - hands - hands
talking together and say oh do you want
to enjoy us of course and come over and
literally without know exactly
delivering and print the whole scene
alive by damn lazy life presence amazing
I learned just know to second with him
HS my whole life you to have sort of
created your own brand like your own
thing we did what in this film did you
get to do that you haven't got to do
before that was inspiring
well let's cast changed your life the
way we actually look and posters are so
different right now we know how to be
become sexy without do anything I knew
this before but better we cats right now
well you knew you were sexy before but
better now but now you're more sexy yes
okay I was saying my muffins of dense
movie change i I'm sorry I better do
better than that
by exactly the same but better than that
like before I was inspected and tense
can be huge like this I always believe
then we can be huge but I always started
them dance does not understand what it
is to be in the bigger scream around the
world and cats literally print that in
life it's not like I won creating other
movies it's just it was just a dance
movies around the story cats have been
here for Wow yeah and nobody brings in a
life and so I have to move her believe
in us to do this he saw us doing it and
he believed in us in every set he made
me felt it made me feel special
every time I don't I feel this for
everybody he make me us feel so special
oh you meow with me come on cat school
Larry
[Music]
so congratulations on the film first of
all thank you yeah I know that's why I
need to hear it hmm yeah more like a
roar kind of guy and I saw a little bit
of what you've done with it another
interview but if I was wonder if there's
anything you can sort of teach me seated
because your movement your cat movements
are off the charts um so um me as a
person like I've always been taught and
throughout my life that um people that
have better posture are more successful
in life so you know when you see me just
walk into a room I'm just like
chest-high
you know and that's just how I live my
life so as a cat I had to learn to be a
little more inside myself you know so in
in this area so as you as you're seated
you you'll be more cat-like if you're
more inside yourself here right and your
eyes change so you felt it yeah I guess
what I'm doing anything cat like I kind
of switch no like I don't know if I'll
ever need this in my life ever again
well I was gonna ask if you that was one
of my questions if you actually learned
anything that you use in your life or
did it change your movements in life no
it's like algebra like you're only gonna
use it in class not that we're telling
people not to study what is your
personal
what is your catnip like for me the
other room like Jennifer and Francesca
said shopping is their thing I know you
like to shop but what is your personal
cabinet I don't like to shop you don't
oh my gosh no I hate going to the mall
I'm a guy right I like to dress nice but
I do not like the shop like I promise
you it's don't cut and lift the worse
thing it's a try on pants like I don't
even have to try on pants when I got to
style it it's like can you try these on
I'm like damn it that's not your cat
mmm food I love food yeah I love going
to restaurants I love ordering by 10
different things off the menu and
tasting everything's I can't decide what
I yeah I'm not everything when I trade
yeah I'm a Virgo I just ask somebody
they're stars I know you went to college
you did musicals in college yeah what
was your sort of first foray into
musicals what was like the first one you
did um in high school was my first foray
and I was just I didn't really know what
it was so I you know always studied
music and one day I was like going past
like this room I know we had theater but
I didn't know like there was musical
theater here I'm saying so going past
one day and they were like doing like
some big big things probably like The
Wiz or something like that and I was
like I'm blown away
they're like singing and dancing and
acting like putting all those things
together on me from that moment on I was
I was hooked I meant to say middle
school that was in middle school so
translating that now to this film you
got to do the movement we know you're an
incredible singer
this is Andrew Lloyd Webber but you put
your own Jason Derulo spin on it for
sure I mean I heard it so just tell me a
little bit about that sort of all that
stuff and from the moment you saw that
as you know in middle school till this
moment on set um so I've watched so many
different rum tum tugger x' and in the
past and I think they're all brilliant
and incredible in their own way and I
just wanted to recreate you know the
idea of rum tum tugger and I think you
know for me it it just this this route
works better you know this the
soulfulness as opposed to the rock side
so you know a lot of time in the mirror
a lot of time videoing myself he's
larger than life you know I'm saying so
like even uh facial expressions you know
just like in your face like really
really big and that's you know who rum
tum tugger is to me you know very
confident in himself in terms of loving
himself but you know on the flip side he
can't decide what he wants in life so
yeah he's very complex well speaking of
which if you're saying you can't decide
what you want in life I feel like with
you like how cats have nine lives you
sort of switch gears like your Instagram
you're doing all this cool stuff now
with your you know being like a
daredevil and you know you get to you
get to I feel like you've gotten to
experience several different lives do
you feel this way yeah 100%
you know that was my new year's
resolution last year's to like live more
um actually it was my new year's
resolution for the last two years and I
couldn't figure out another like a
better thing to do so like I decided to
make my resolution two times I mean it's
been incredible you know like jumping
off of buildings swimming with sharks
you know I don't know like snowboarding
just like doing like things that I would
you know never imagined but also
different you talking about different
lives the entrepreneurial side almost at
13 businesses now and that's like get a
rush from making a successful business
you know it's its life just been
incredible to just choose things that
I'm I love that I'm into you know and
just kind of cultivate those things and
the movie side so this is my first film
but actually been writing films as well
and that's like a new bug you know that
I have as well how do you feel like
you're most like a cat in life I'm a
bigger guy
I'm almost 200 pounds so I don't know
yeah I'm a dense guy yeah I don't think
I'm really much like a cat do you have a
pet name do you have like a daddy daddy
yeah not cat daddy just daddy just dad
really is that known wait do I feel like
somebody know this
it's not known it's like a more of a
personal thing but I thought I'd share
with you is there so the set there was
like the props were so large like
everything was larger than obviously
built to scale is there a process I feel
like you're like larger than life is
there a prop you would like to have
brought home to your house um yeah and I
meant to bring it but I just forgot to
get it
it was the milk bar sign and yeah I
think I gotta call somebody to see if I
still get that because it's just like
such a part of my journey um okay so
just that that big milk boy it's like I
don't know where the hell I would put it
though this film obviously great
incredible voices you at Jennifer Hudson
Taylor Swift any moments on set that
we're kind of interesting or different
or something that um I just think
everything was awe-inspiring you know so
much that you kind of get used to
amazing things like it was just amazing
things happen every day with different
people um because you just have some of
the best talents in the world all in one
room you know I'm saying and I was like
a revolving door of like these
incredible people that are walking in
and kind of leaving and then you know
other people are walking in it's like
it's just incredible
you